[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines des actions sont menées pour
venir en aide au sinistre du séisme qui
a sévi au Maroc le 8 septembre dernier
la mosquée de Guyancourt a notamment
lancé une collecte de dons en ligne la
région Île-de-France se mobilise avec un
fond d'urgence humanitaire de 500000
euros et le Secours populaire des
Yvelines débloque un fond de 5000 euros
fin des fortes chaleurs dans les
Yvelines après une semaine de canicule
les orages sont attendus des mardi 12
septembre mais la sécheresse est
toujours d'actualité le 8 septembre
dernier la région sud-est des Yvelines
était placée en situation d'alerte par
la préfecture ce week-end c'était le
forum des associations à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à Coignières
les habitants étaient au rendez-vous une
quarantaine d'associations étaient
présentes au gymnase du moulin à vent
c'est un moment où déjà les associations
se retrouvent et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important de pouvoir se retrouver en
un lieu on touche quand même d'autres
publics notamment par nos petites
démonstrations et puis les
les nouveaux adhérents aiment bien
rencontrer aussi nos professeurs donc
c'est aussi en plus de participer à ce
forum nos adhérences sont aussi bien des
enfants à partir de 4 ans pour le judo
le modelage et alors la pâte limite
d'âge pour les randonneurs les plus
anciens ont plus de 80 ans et voilà